criminal defense lawyer wrote to me over
the weekend tears in his eyes I could
tell even though it was an email that
the guy was crying as he wrote to me and
he said David listen I'm a criminal
defense attorney where Trump can get
himself into real trouble here
is if he has a gag order placed on him
at tomorrow's arraignment
he may not be able to resist talking
about the case and that would be
considered a bond violation and it could
get Trump rearrested the latest news is
that a gag order is quote extremely
likely at tomorrow's arraignment
and Donald Trump has scheduled a press
conference for tomorrow evening okay so
this has this is a secondary story which
has the potential to completely explode
into a very different sort of situation
than this coordinated very dignified
arrest that is taking place tomorrow in
New York City Business Insider reports
let's go through it piece by piece a gag
order for Donald Trump is extremely
likely once he's before a judge legal
expert says Donald Trump can't seem to
stop talking about his indictment but he
may have to soon it's extremely likely
he'll be put under gag order one expert
said punishment in New York for criminal
contempt could be a one thousand dollar
fine or 30 days in jail such a gag order
would say to Trump and others involved
in the case do not speak publicly about
the case and yet an announcement from
yesterday that Donald Trump tomorrow
will be holding a press conference about
the arraignment in Marvel the
announcement coming on Trump make
America great again 2024 letterhead
naturally and it says Tuesday April 4 8
15 Eastern that's tomorrow evening
president Donald J Trump 45th president
of the United States will deliver
remarks at Mar-A-Lago in Palm Beach
Florida at 8 15. this is expected to be
not only remarks but a press conference
if there is a gag order
and Donald Trump doesn't cancel that
event
and he speaks about the case against him
he would be subject to re-arrest now I
know people are saying 30 days in jail
with trump it would probably be the
thousand dollar fine let's be completely
honest but it would make him subject to
rearrest and in all seriousness none of
them were crying when they emailed me
that I know of but numerous lawyers
wrote to me and said this is really
where Trump has to be careful the next
question mark which I believe is of
utter importance is whether this
arraignment will be televised as many of
my viewers and listeners of course know
I have many family members who work in
the field of mental health and I think
one of the most important things that we
can do is to both increase access and
reduce stigma when it comes to Mental
Health Services and that's why I am
thrilled that one of our sponsors today
is better help better help is the
world's largest therapy service and it
is 100 online with better help you can
tap into a network of over 25 000
licensed and experienced therapists an
important word therapists who can help
you with a wide range of issues you
answer a few questions about your needs
and your preferences and better help
will match you with a therapist that
meets your needs you can then talk to
your therapist however you feel
comfortable could be text could be chat
phone video call you can message your
therapist anytime you can schedule live
sessions when it's convenient and if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but it's on your
schedule
and it's at a more affordable price get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below